foreign  I think it centers everything around uh  Robin because the book is about Robin it  explores this relationship with Bruce  and you know not just Bruce but Alfred  in this case it you know it does take an  entire league to kind of you know raise  Robin and make him who he is Jeff and I  we really made it where everyone else is  the way they are because of Batman I  trust him with a great story and he  trusts me with you know an art in return  that's what I always felt you know  creating Comics should be like a really  really cool story and you want to draw  it and then you draw and then you know  people read it and they enjoy it I you  know I absolutely love drawing killer  Crocs Croc is one of those characters  that crosses both sides he's visually  like very scary and just as crazy  foreign  [Music]